[Música]
[Aplausos]
sí
y una persona que pueda la primera
edición del club tiene accidente de
seguridad y tercera ruedas vacunarlos
muy bien cómo esta persona
o sea el problema cognitivo que conoce
la vida de los demás
como si cómo vamos en sus piernas
cosas tan importante información de las
acciones sean por lo que no es el
cliente y los vecinos
el fútbol
pero en un
tantas cosas que son inactivas
y cuando se le otorgaron a unirse con
gente
y aprovecha para correr
imaginen la noticia
[Música]
con el imaginarme el paso como de
izquierda
los dos y les ofrece
pero el presente y creo que en este
momento aumentarán de oportunidades en
mis piernas
d
estábamos en el centro y sufrimos
reciente explicó
[Música]
pero no
sí
de única de la razón
[Música]
son 12 frutas en la visión
recuperando
[Música]
clásica internacional en la cama
y yo
[Música]
una vibración que mira al pasillo quizás
trotar hace tanto tiempo que hoy en par
de ocasiones se aprende a ser muy y
haber día hay un derecho sin tocar para
la gente y era eso fue una era una
herramienta inmigración y me ayuda mucho
y en ese sentido ayuda de la capacidad
de racionamiento lo diría mejor
cuando el alma
vamos a hacer la rehabilitación con mi
mamá durante cuatro meses para que me
enseñaron mucho sobre el cuidado del
cuerpo alimentarnos ciencia ahora
bastante por sí solo de hecho
de mantener mi cuerpo más sano posible
voy a crear más
un poco más y permisibilidad tres años
solo con mis activos sólo si nuestros
padres
somos conocidos mindy desde el inicio
para viajes a partir perros antes
en el fin de semana
llamada
sí sí
[Música]
sin saberlo garantía de emociones y
seguridad acabaron con esta pregunta se
preguntaba
[Música]